[Music]
you must be people that come up to you
with Thor jokes all the time that you
know just is you're so who are Thor you
get you get the the same jokes pretty
much in fact the same single joke I've
had for three years now
really it's not very funny but I can
tell it to if you want you're on the
right show trust me
so basically four meets this this young
maiden and they sleep with one another
have a wonderful night the next morning
for says you know fair maiden I must
confess until you I am I'm Thor and she
says you're for I can hardly walk the
timing on that was perfect I was 50
seconds boom I like I like the long
pause so how many times have you heard
that joke people have said that to you
hard about 300 times
yeah I gotta use that one that's right
you know it's so much the fans I mean
just your the reaction of the people
here when you came out and and and the
fans are so devoted to you and to the
film's the fan art is incredible and
very silly
what's the same thing there's been many
crazy fan out kind of reproductions of
certain things and yet with the fall
yeah Thoris I think we have some that's
my hair commercial that's you you should
try and get that out there is still
enough perhaps
yeah and there's pasta yeah very nice
that one that's my favorite so that was
actually me that was um yeah that was me
you will get a lorry you'll get a hair
at I'm sure they're coming to you and
they're asking have you seen because
Halloween couple days ago you you have
you ever run into an adulterer kids
dressed as Thor and had to deal with
that yeah a lot of the sort of comic-con
conventions and things you see it but I
was at the airport a few weeks ago and
this little kid was running around in
the the full for outfit is you hammer
any smashing things and and his mother
was there and she came up and she said
and grabs her son she look look it's its
third thought he looked it up and a good
what I thought and without the costume
yeah he then hit you in the knee a twist